now the Press can barely contain itself
it's like Christmas morning the Super
Bowl and the World Series all rolled
into one it's filled with gifts
celebrations and of course entertainment
the hype and the distraction never ends
for so many people they've waited for
the stay to see some some accountability
in terms of criminal acts by the former
president it's really dramatic stuff and
it's uh it's never happened before in
American history we're all going to be
glued leaning forward to our television
sets on Tuesday the NYPD is requiring
all officers to be in uniform starting
today you can see the barricades that
are up
this courthouse and even across the
street
ooh barricades now obviously Trump's
indictment is a huge story but not to
the exclusion of every other big story
like the facts that you know Biden has
taken a sledgehammer to our national
prosperity and our national security
those minor stories
not to mention his constantly sowing
National Discord
you know that all love at the White
House if California's reparation
movement would spread Nationwide that's
their dream they love what's happening
in Sacramento
real simple
just direct cash payments they owe me
and mine reparations repair and real
estate
and they certainly do not want you to
dwell on the fact that many blue states
are just dissolving before our eyes
especially all those big cities like
Philly LA and Chicago
even liberal Washington Post columnist
Philip bump cannot ignore these trend
lines saying rural counties added about
207 000 new residents from migration
while Urban counties lost 328 thousand
the counties that backed Trump by at
least 10 points in 2020 added nearly 1.2
million residents
well of course it looks like things and
Ukraine are going south as well
and there's more disturbing news growing
out of China they're getting more
aggressive and they're crossing over the
Taiwanese uh Straits and into the across
the median line there another
provocation that will go unanswered by
Washington and no doubt why are Biden
still begging he's begging G for a
meeting
the president has said clearly he
believes it's important to keep the
lines of communication with China open
he wants to have another conversation
with President XI we'll move in that
direction
the danger for president Trump is that
he too though will get distracted from
selling his solutions to families who
are suffering all over the United States
getting sucked into a war of words over
Alvin Bragg's persecution that would
leave Trump's major Nemesis Joe Biden
free to just stumble across an open
field without having to defend his
abhorrent record
well we can't allow that to happen hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else